Andrew McCabe the former acting director
of the FBI continues to make more and
more and more of very explosive claims
most recently saying last night to
Anderson Cooper that it's possible that
the current President of the United
States is a Russian asset so let's reset
over the weekend Andrew McCabe was
interviewed on 60 minutes and that sixty
minutes interview contained a number of
explosive claims to put it lightly
Andrew McCabe said that it was not
sarcasm when it was claimed that rod
Rosenstein considered wearing a wire
after James Comey was fired when he
spoke to President Trump
Andrew McCabe says no that that really
happened Andrew McCabe explained that he
opened an obstruction probe into Donald
Trump to try to create an infrastructure
that would not so easily allow for the
investigation to be shut down in the
event that Andrew McCabe was pushed out
which of course he eventually was and
Andrew McCabe also told us in that 60
minutes interview that there was a
serious discussion within the Justice
Department about the possibility of
using the 25th amendment to have the
cabinet of Donald Trump remove him for
being unfit to serve or unable to carry
out the duties of the presidency that's
just the sixty minutes interview we then
get to Anderson Cooper's show last night
and Anderson Cooper asked is it possible
that the president is indeed a Russian
asset and the former acting director of
the FBI said it is possible and that
that possibility was actually what led
to the opening of an investigation do
you still believe the president could be
a Russian asset I think it's possible I
think that's why we started our
investigation and I'm really anxious to
see where director Muller concludes that
this is not some random uninformed
partisan political pundit speaking
extemporaneously this is someone who was
the former acting director or was the
acting director of the FBI who bases
his knowledge and involvement on what is
actually in the possession of the FBI
and who is going to base his comments on
a program like Anderson Cooper's on the
basis of firsthand involvement in these
investigations and what he is saying is
he can't rule out the possibility that
Donald Trump the President of the United
States is an asset of Russia we've
talked before about the distinction
between asset and agent and I know that
there are some people in the audience
who when I brought this up wrote to me
and said well you know David it that
there is a semantic difference there but
the terms are sort of used
interchangeably maybe it's not a big
deal that may be true but let's just be
very clear because when Andrew McCabe
uses the term asset he's talking about
something very specific an agent of
Russia in general would suggest like an
active intelligence officer or some kind
of formal relationship to Russia that's
not what Andrew McCabe is suggesting
here what Andrew McCabe is saying is
that there's a possibility that Trump is
an asset an asset is something possessed
and used by someone else and what this
could suggest and this has been my
feeling for a while now it's not that
Donald Trump is even necessarily
knowingly working to advance the Russian
agenda but he's doing it because he's
been manipulated for years and it's
actually better for the foreign power if
Trump doesn't think he's actually acting
at their direction if he thinks he's
making all of these decisions himself
and I was thinking back to the list at
this point which is an increasingly
growing list of actions that Donald
Trump has taken which don't prove that
he is an aware proactive agent of Russia
but have effectively transformed him
into a de facto asset of Russia let's go
through the list number one publicly
taking the side of Russia and Putin over
our own intelligence agencies he's done
this at this point dozens of times and
we just learned that in private he
literally said I don't care what
American intelligence says I believe
Putin at least on the issue of
Korea's weapons capabilities number two
Trump's refusal to enforce sanctions
that are in the law against Russia and
the reversal of existing sanctions
Donald Trump has done both we told you
recently that Donald Trump is ending the
joint nuclear agreement which opens the
door to Russia further arming itself
does it matter whether Trump thinks he's
doing it because it's better for America
or because he's doing it because it's
good for Putin if it's good for Putin
and if it's good for Russia then Trump
is assisting them in what they want to
have happen number four multiple lies
about Donald Trump's interests in Russia
even if Trump is lying out of stupidity
about the extent to which Trump Tower
Moscow was being explored it's still
good for Russia that Donald Trump
appears to be evasive and dishonest
about it because it simply raises more
questions about why that's good for
Russia number five or maybe six at this
point I don't know I'm losing track
Trump's threats to pull out of NATO even
if Trump has reasons that he believes
are good reasons to pull out of NATO
that have nothing to do with Russia that
plays directly into the Russian priority
of destabilizing NATO causing chaos in
the geopolitical West number six or
seven withdrawal from Syria withdrawal
from Syria is counter to what every
relevant expert says make sense in the
way that Trump is proposing it still
hasn't happened by the way it's not
clear if it will but it plays directly
into Russian geopolitical priorities so
at this point Pat this is not defensible
period the only argument there is is one
over whether Trump is knowingly doing
this stuff to benefit Russia or whether
he believes that he has his own reasons
and it just happens to be exactly what
Russia wants him to do I think that
Trump being a Russian asset makes a lot
more sense than him being a Russian
agent I just don't think he's smart
enough to be a Russian agent he would
accidentally admit to it on national TV
like how he admitted to Lester Holt that
he fired James Comey over the Russia
investigation or
how he admitted recently that he didn't
have to declare a national emergency I
don't think he can think that many moves
ahead and I think that he is being
manipulated but he doesn't fully know it
yeah at minimum we have an unambiguous
series of events that show Donald Trump
is betraying American interests in the
favor of Russia and the extent to which
this is coordinated puppeteering by
Russia or not we just don't know we may
never know and most importantly and I'm
going to be going back to this a lot in
the coming what is it 11 9 28 21 months
I guess it is until the election Donald
Trump may well get reelected in 2020
which would be an indictment not just on
Trump voters but also on anti Trump
voters who choose to stay home and I
know that I'm going to get emails saying
David you really shouldn't be
preemptively blaming people who don't
like Trump I'm not what I'm saying is
when 50% of the country doesn't vote if
Donald Trump gets reelected it's not
just because his base supports him it's
also because not enough people who don't
support Trump voted it's just a
mathematical reality and it's a very
plausible reality not probable I won't
say at this point but it's a very
plausible reality that Donald Trump will
indeed be reelected we have a poll out
right now on YouTube and Instagram
asking what are you going to use as
information to evaluate who you will
vote for in the 2020 Democratic primary
you can find this on the YouTube
community tab as well as on the David
Pakman show
Instagram page which is at David Pakman
show participate boat and we will have
results hopefully for you tomorrow
today's program is sponsored in part by
spresso bucks who are offering everybody
in our audience a bunch of really cool
free stuff suppressor Vox is a company
based in New York City and they are
going to make your life a lot easier and
save you money when it comes to keeping
up with men's fashion because when you
sign up for spreads about you'll get a
totally new box sent to
every month with five or six hand-picked
accessories and pieces of clothing
you'll get things like really stylish
socks neckties high-end sunglasses
wallets watches bracelets high-quality
pens and hair combs the list goes on but
it's all really nice stuff must-haves
for any guy who's wanting to update his
wardrobe I got some really cool stuff in
my espresso box including a money clip
as well as a very nice pocket square and
some really good-looking socks all of
which are very very cool thus preserve a
subscription is just 25 bucks a month
but you definitely come out ahead
because every box every single month is
guaranteed to have items with a combined
value of over $100 so they make it easy
to keep your outfits fresh but you're
also getting a lot of bang for your buck
and it makes a really great gift for a
guy in your life everyone in our
audience can get one month totally free
when you click the link underneath this
video and use the promo code Pakman
that's PA que ma n